you are watching the press preview her
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the journalist and author christina
patterson and the columnist at the
article ali mirage so let's see what's
on some of those front pages for you now
the observer leads with neil parish the
mp who says he'll resign after watching
porn in the commons with labour claiming
he's committed a criminal offence
the common speaker lindsey hoyle is
calling for an overhaul of working
practices in parliament after a number
of allegations against mps writes the
sunday times
the sunday telegraph goes with the
conservatives saying half of the party's
mps returned at the next election must
be women
the sunday express says mi5 has briefed
the home secretary pretty patel about
fears vladimir putin will send saboteurs
to the uk
a woman claims levi bellfield fathered a
secret son weeks before killing mili
daola that's according to the sunday
mirror
and the star has an interview with an
actress who appeared in the tv comedy
alo alo
and reminded that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and i'm joined tonight by christina
patterson and ali mirage welcome to you
both good to see you let's start with
the
observer and the story that's um well
been everywhere for the last few days
this is neil parish the disgraced
mp uh the question now being posed is
whether he actually broke the law ally
look it's a very very uh
bad uh time for neil parish obviously
he's done the right thing
and resigned he absolutely the right
thing to do i think his position was
really untenable and this comes a very
difficult time for the conservative
party just a week out from uh local
elections now
uh very very bad timing but also it
comes at a time when parliament itself
has had a number of issues uh in recent
weeks we had liam burn a labour mp
suspended for bullying uh this week we
had the whole
fiasco over angela rainer and whether
she was crossing around crossing her
legs to distract the prime minister very
unedifying we had the john burko
bullying investigation the pretty patel
bullying investigation
and we've had a number of um
parliamentarians also suspended on child
abuse uh uh issues which uh have they've
been found guilty of both in the lords
and the commons so it's really bad and
there's 56 cases apparently out there of
accusations against parliamentarians of
sexual abuse of one kind or the other so
this is not um an isolated issue
obviously neil parrish has done the
right thing but it also
it comes at a time when there's going to
be another by-election now in tibetan
and honeton and you remember what
happened last december in north
shropshire when owen patterson had to
stand down another rock solitary seat
tiverton and honeston is exactly the
kind of place where
despite the fact that the tory's about
60 of the vote
and the liberal democrats uh 10
percent-ish that is exactly the kind of
place where they could make inroads and
give the tories a bloody nose well as
ali uh suggesting there christina it's
been a pretty torrid time all round uh
in the world of politics but this
incident with uh neil parish how much
damage do you think it has done to the
conservative party and boris johnson's
government particularly just before
these local elections
i think it's probably done a lot of
damage to the conservative party but
almost more worryingly all of this just
hugely diminishes people's respect for
politicians generally i mean as ali says
there are 56 mps under investigation for
uh
sexual offenses of one kind or another
and that includes three cabinet
ministers and two shadow cabinet
ministers so i'm afraid we i do think
the tory party certainly it has gives
the impression of being infinitely worse
in the labour party but i think overall
i must say when we're facing such
incredibly serious issues the war in
ukraine the cost of living crisis which
makes it sound kind of cozy and you know
we'll talk about that later but we are
talking extreme poverty for many many
people which is quite shocking in this
country of a kind that we probably
haven't seen for decades actually it's
really extremely depressing and i feel
upsetting to feel that these issues are
in the hands of people who are sitting
watching porn or
groping their ass distance or their
stuff or bullying their staff or getting
drunk on the job or any number of other
sleazy offenses that have been popping
up in recent weeks i mean none of this
stuff would be tolerated in any other
workplace obviously i'm a journalist i
worked on a newspaper for 10 years as a
staff journalist and i didn't see this
kind of stuff going on at all newspapers
are famously testosterone-fueled
places to work so i i think it's very
very unedifying and i hope that
i hope that something can be done to
reform it but i just think yes all of
this reduces people's respect for the
tories and i hope that will be reflected
in the local elections and i hope that
will be reflected in the general
election but all in all it makes you
feel that we just don't have a political
system that's fit for purpose or that
represents the people of this country
accurately this is not how most people
conduct themselves in the workplace and
the fact that our elected
representatives do is really really
disgraceful and alien the telegraph we
we read that the conservative party is
uh going to try to contain the sleaze
and deal with the the culture at
westminster suggesting that half of
their mps will be women come at the next
general election
well uh julian i'll believe it when i
see it um the conservatives have made a
lot of statements in the past about
wanting to increase representation uh
not only from uh women but also from the
ethnic minorities uh they have made
inroads into that to be fair to them
over the last 20 years or so
but a lot more needs to be done but i
think you know unless they're going to
talk about quotas and i personally am
not a fan of approaches i think that we
need to find other ways of doing it i
know the labour party have been very
successful uh with their all women
shortlist to really boost the numbers uh
in parliament and you know credit to
them for doing that i've never really
been a fan of quotas but i think the
tory party if it's serious it's got to
put its money where its mouth is now
you've got um ann jenkin the wife of
bernard jenkins who set up women to win
an internal sort of campaign group if
you like within the party that's done a
lot to men to bring on uh women's talent
etc but a lot more needs to be done and
the thing that i've always found in
parliament is that you really want a
diversity of opinion you want to avoid
group things so just putting in a bunch
of public school uh women with exactly
the same sort of mindset as a bunch of
public school men
which is some improvement but it's not
total improvement what we need is
complete diversity working class people
people from the north people from all
around the country to really trying to
give us a representative parliament so
that we do not end up in group thing and
the culture of that place
does need to change it's a weird place i
mean christina knows this any of us who
spend time in parliament over the years
know this the opposition's trying to
trip you up your own side stabbing you
in the back uh journalists uh and people
operate in the media like me are trying
to trip them up it's not it's an odd
you're working long hours you're away
from your family it's just not normal
but that is not an excuse for the kind
of behavior that we've seen not only
from neil parish but from others and it
does need to be cleaned up
that sounds like a perfect advert for
anyone who wants to go into politics not
um christina what do you think needs to
be done is this some way to address the
culture within westminster by seeking to
to have more female mps is that part of
the way to the solution at least
i think ultimately it probably is part
of a way to a solution but the thing is
when when ali talks about uh
politics and in particular the tory
party needing more diversity he's right
but unfortunately we have a prime
minister who doesn't countenance any
diversity at all when we saw the cabinet
that he appointed in 2019 and has
broadly maintained it was made up of
essentially clones i mean sure there was
a bit of you know a little bit of racial
diversity and yes there are prominent
women like pretty patel
um but unfortunately the the general
message that he sent out and clearly
intended to send out was that no
diversity of thought would be tolerated
if you weren't a hard line brexiter if
you didn't subscribe to boris johnson's
own particular vision invented of course
to win the election i mean he doesn't
have a vision for the tory party he
doesn't care about the tory party what
he cares about is boris johnson and
boris johnson staying in power for no
reason that that is evident to any of
the rest of us except that apparently he
quite likes power
quickly christina do you think that
there can be diversity of thought when
people are from the same background or
do you think that's impossible no i
don't i think it's extremely unlikely
and i think the fact that the seven
percent of the population who went to
private school have always been so
overrepresented in parliament and in all
the institutions of this country is is
you know means that you never get any
kind of you know the diversity of
thought you get is extremely narrow but
i think this has to go you have to admit
i i oliver dowden has talked in his
dream of getting 50 representation he's
talked about getting the brightest and
the best
women um particularly people but also in
particular women in this particular
situation how he's going to get those
when we have a culture of law breaking
rule breaking and lying in parliament
how on earth that's going to attract the
brightest let alone the best i mean that
is just for the birds isn't it so i
think or any dream of diversity let
alone of integrity is completely lost
when you have this bunch of charlatans
in charge
yeah ali did you want to come in very
quickly
yeah very quickly there's also a
practical issue if the tories are really
going to get 50 of their
parliamentarians as i read it
in parliament representing them then
there's a structural problem here
because
they've only got 25 at the moment so
what does this mean are they going to
force out a lot of
what we call bed blockers politely who
are coming to the end of their terms of
polymer they're going to push them out
and then replace them with the women how
practically are they going to do this
because we've heard this rhetoric before
i i mean there are a certain number of
retirement seats that come up the safe
seats that we call them in the tory
party are they going to get them all to
women or are they actually going to push
out some of the existing people in there
and say look your time's up move on make
make space for um some women to come in
so i i don't know
it'll be interesting to see how they
achieve this at this ambition um ali and
christina for the moment thank you we
are going to take a break coming up
leading tories are calling for a new
cost of living minister to sort out the
crisis we'll be discussing that after
the break
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me journalist and
author christina patterson and the
columnist at the article ali mirage
let's have a look in this section at the
sunday express first of all and this
story about uh putin's army of saboteurs
uh target britain this at first glance
is extremely worrying ally
it is extremely worrying and this is uh
us potentially being in the front line
of this uh
uh war that putin's waging against
ukraine and we know that uh boris
johnson is very close now to vladimir
zelinski we have really led the way
in providing uh anti-aircraft missiles
uh now we're pushing for tanks and now
uh also this trust wants to give planes
and uh russia wants to retaliate this is
uh talking about potentially direct
attacks on british soil of some kind we
don't know exactly what form that would
take but we know that the russians in
the past have got form on this 2006
alexander litvinyenko a big critic of
putin was poisoned uh uh with polonium
in the uk uh also uh the skripals sergey
and julius grippel were targeted in
salisbury in 2018 which resulted in the
death of an innocent woman uh dawn
sturgeon so we also know
that cyber attacks are something that
the the russians are very good at in
2015 they closed down the ukrainian
power network for
a number of hours so uh they're expert
in this thing and and engage in
plausible deniability so critical
infrastructure uh could be in their
sights at the cyber attacks extremely
worrying it is uh we read that the the
prime minister and his chief of staff
steve barkley have been informed of the
situation while gchq is understood to be
liaising with european colleagues and
senior officers at mi5 have briefed
pretty patel and her team about the high
level threat
christina
yeah i mean every every thing to do with
this war is absolutely terrifying and i
have to say i of course i support the uk
uh helping to provide lethal weapons
helping to support zelensky too because
clearly
justice and truth is on his side and it
would be
terrible if ukraine lost this war but
i'm afraid i don't support liz trusts
the kind of ratcheting up of the stakes
in a way that seems to me
unnecessary and very very dangerous and
people who know that
he she did that in her talk to manchin
house a couple of nights ago when she
said that
that we support ukraine not only in
winning this war but also in going back
pre-2014 which ukraine isn't even asking
for in expelling russia from crimea and
uh the territories it's occupied since
then and you know ukraine if ukraine
isn't asking for it it's not up to us
for uh to ask for these things and i'm
afraid i do think this puts us we are at
risk and and of course you know we
should stand with ukraine but i think
it's very hard to see a good outcome to
this and putin could not be more
dangerous and i think the people who've
been observing him closely like fiona
hill in the us who is one of the sort of
you know kind of key russia experts in
the world has said that she thinks there
is you know a serious likelihood of
putin using nuclear weapons so i really
do think that the west absolutely has to
support ukraine but it's not up to us to
escalate it's up to ukraine to say okay
what it wants and us to support them
while not doing anything to bring on
world war iii which at the moment looks
quite likely we've just got time for a
quick word from uh ali on the idea for a
new cost of living minister
look i don't think we need more gimmicks
i think we need action uh the cost of
living minister as far as i'm concerned
is the chancellor he's got a really
difficult job to do he's got a rising
interest rate environment uh rising
inflation and 400 billion of borrowing
to contend with he's saying he said this
week in a mom's net uh interview that it
would be silly to introduce more
measures right now i understand where
he's coming from because he wants to
wait till october to try and do it but
october is a very long way away and i
think he's going to be under a lot of
pressure to take more action he wants to
keep it in the locker because he also
wants to make tax cuts ahead of the next
election but i just don't think the
political pressure around him is going
to abate and i feel that he's probably
going to take more action but it's not
going to be easy for him
ali and christina thank you both for
this hour we'll see you in the next 60
minutes thank you